it's the most important day in the
academic calendar
and it's being held under tough covid19
restrictions
as south korea fights through a third
wave of the pandemic
it's in stark contrast to what is
traditionally
a celebration that brings everyone
together
in a society obsessed with academic
achievement
[Music]
younger pupils and family members
normally throng the schools as the
students arrive for the exam
police provide escorts for those running
late
and even flight departure times are
adjusted
so planes don't disturb exam takers
this year all students are carefully
checked while distancing measures are
being strictly observed
for examinees and invigilators alike
special evening classes known as cram
schools
which are normally busy preparing
students ahead of the exam
have mostly suspended operations as part
of the government's efforts to ensure
safety
i urge all people including examinees to
follow the prevention rules in your
daily lives
what hasn't changed is just how
important this day is in the lives of
students and their families
this exam will determine which college
they get into
and so influence their career paths
afterwards
it doesn't get much bigger at temples
across
south korea families have been praying
for exam success
but also probably for their children to
stay safe
special arrangements have been made for
infected students
to take the exam in hospital and south
korea's president
has been seeing for himself special
centers set up for students who are
self-isolating
i had various concerns but today looking
at the preparations
i am somewhat relieved however the covet
19 situation is now worse than when we
first
planned for this day already under
incredible exam pressure
students this year have the added
concerns of the pandemic
to stress over rob mcbride al jazeera
seoul